después de casi 12 años de guerra en
Siria que dejaron las infraestructuras
en ruinas como el conflicto que vive esa
región magnificó la tragedia en una zona
con miles de desplazados internos y
refugiados
sí efectivamente el terremoto viene
precisamente a llover sobre mojado en
Siria la zona precisamente más afectada
fue la zona más afectada por el
conflicto precisamente la zona noroeste
de Siria es la zona donde más habitada
por por gente desplazada que ya vivían
previamente en condiciones muy precarias
Y que ahora mismo están viviendo una
situación límite la verdad la ayuda
humanitaria está llegando a cuentagotas
a otras zonas de Siria pero a la zona
precisamente más densamente poblada por
la gente más afectada por el conflicto
hasta este momento simplemente se están
estudiando
opciones Por lo cual ya pasaron las
primeras 72 horas que siempre son
cruciales en ese tipo de eventos Y
todavía están esperando soluciones que
no llegan ahora el gobierno sirio dice
que las ayudas deben pasar por Damasco y
que la comunidad internacional debe
levantar las sanciones en su contra
impuestas a causa de la guerra está
aprovechándose a Sad de la coyuntura de
la tragedia para hacerse con el control
de estas zonas opositoras y politizar
así estas ayudas humanitarias
el régimen de asad nunca cesó de
intentar politizar las ayudas
humanitarias con la ayuda con la ayuda
por supuesto del principal Arial Aliado
que es Rusia y este Este es un una
ocasión Esta es una ocasión de oro para
ellos y lo estamos viendo muy claramente
el régimen está intentando
imponerse como única vía de canalización
Por lo cual es lo cual es muy
problemático porque existen evidencias
durante años de que la cúpula del
régimen se ha estado enriqueciéndose muy
fuertemente gracias a las ayudas
humanitarias pero he de decir también
que esas reservas acerca del régimen
intentando politizar las aduras no
deberían ser motivo para que la
comunidad internacional no actúe de
inmediato para intentar salvar a los
sirios que ahora mismo estás viviendo
una situación realmente límite Por
supuesto que es algo preocupante por
supuesto que el régimen sirio no es Pero
ese no es motivo para la apatía que
estamos viendo ahora según la agencia de
la ONU para asuntos humanitarios los
flujos de ayuda desde Turquía se Han
detenido debido a los daños por los
terremotos algunos sirios están
organizando protestas en el cruce de
Baba al agua Cuál es el papel de Turquía
en el acceso a estas ayudas a través de
su territorio
ahora mismo
bajo el mandato del mecanismo
transfronterizo de la ONU existe un
acuerdo internacional para usar
precisamente el paso fronterizo de
bávaro como único cordón umbilical a la
zona fuera del control del régimen eso
es un mandato de la ONU que precisamente
se renovó hace un par de meses ese paso
fronterizo ahora mismo está
prácticamente cerrado porque las
autopistas de acceso desde Turquía están
seriamente dañadas con lo cual urge que
tanto Turquía como los organismos
internacionales como la ONU misma
ofrezca alternativas porque si no esta
zona está en
en un estado de sitio de facto no hay no
hay acceso por ningún otro lado y la
verdad es no es de recibo que se tarde
tanto tiempo en buscar una solución
alternativa Por supuesto que esa zona
que la zona de enfrente en Turquía es la
zona más dañada las alternativas por
supuesto no serán fáciles pero es Es
imposible que la situación Siga así